well uh and now for the main event of
the evening again the resolution reads
and go capitalism would definitely be a
complete disaster for Humanity taking
the affirmative on that resolution yaren
Brooke yaron please come to the stage
uh taking the negative opposing the
resolution Brian Kaplan Brian please
come to the stage
[Applause]
Jane please close the voting and uh
yaron you can take the podium you have
15 minutes to defend the resolution
ticket take it away uh the I'm sorry
yeah there will be a gentleman in front
flashing you time cards uh take it away
yaron
thank you guys thank you Gene and thank
you Brian for agreeing to do this uh
this debate
uh and and and I know it's two against
one so
uh we all know where Gene sympathy is
like
you remember that part of the movie
Braveheart
where uh Mel Gibson yells freedom
what is he yelling what does that even
mean
what are they what's their conception of
freedom
back then is it the kind of idea we have
I think in this room of individual
liberty of individual freedom of
individuals using their mind to pursue
their values
free or absence of coercion
or is it the kind of freedom of my gang
over your gang
my bloodline over your bloodline
I want to be ruled by a Scottish King
God forbid I be ruled by a British one
that of course is the way the world was
for almost ever
gangs against gangs
there's no
you know with some exceptions here in
their Central authorities that didn't
emerge out of Civil Wars out of Anarchy
out of a situation where people are
battling each other for
policing Authority
for power
security agencies of this tribe of that
tribe battling each other to see who
would rule over everyone else
Freedom as we understand it
is a massive intellectual
achievement intellectual cultural
political
achievement
an achievement of ideas
the idea of individual rights the idea
of individual liberty individual freedom
is a consequence of the thinking of
philosophers of thinkers economists for
Generations
and it's a political manifestation
it's political manifestation was the
achievement of
a political system
that yes gave government created an
entity with a monopoly over the use of
force
but the limited that use of force or at
least try to at least for a period on
some people it was not it was flawed
granted
over how it used that Force
with the idea that this is what was
required in order for individuals to
have their Liberty to have their freedom
for individuals to be able to be free
because to be free
coercion must be extracted from the
equation
is not something one negotiates violence
is not something one arbitrates violence
is something that should be avoided it
should be extracted
and what I think the think is
that brought us the idea of individual
rights and they created a country that
was based on it again with all its flaws
what they realized was you needed a
monopoly over the use of force over the
use of retaliatory force and for Force
only to be used in retaliation
now in my view to be free the key
concept for freedom is individual rights
it's the idea that every individual has
a way to his life
in other words he has the freedom to act
again based on his judgment in pursuit
of his values
in the absence of collision
and the protection of individual rights
necessitates
a government
it necessitates some kind of Institution
that actually serves to extract that
coercion from society
an institution that subordinates
Society
to this moral idea of Rights
that doesn't just happen that's not
something you negotiate
that is just something that is
it is a requirement
for human thriving for human flourishing
for freedom
so individual rights necessity
government
in order to Bar physical Force
from social relationships which we seem
to I think all think that's a worthwhile
cause borrowing physical force and
social relationship well who's going to
do that
how is it going to be objectively done
how do we agree what force is in every
circumstances how do we do restitution
and retribution
all of those need a mechanism they need
a mechanism an objective mechanism a
mechanism of the rule of law
and over a particular geographic area
that requires a monopoly
so one objective law
in one Geographic one geographic
location
where the use of force is under the
control guidance
of an objective law determined by reason
so a proper government
is the means by which
we place retaliatory use of force under
objective control
and objectively defined laws in order
for the purpose
of protecting rights
now notice we talk about capitalism we
talk about free markets free markets
but
free markets assume something
they assume there's no Collision this
human there's no Force that's what
Freedom means markets to be free you
have to be free of coercion
so the absence of coercion the
elimination of corrosion comes first
the idea that defense agencies can
compete on a quote free market for
retaliatory force is incoherent
for free market is one from which force
has effectively already been banished
what
what defense agencies are actually
trading and isn't forced
in the lack of freedom
in the use of its negation
so
freedom
the ability of the individual to use
this judgment for his own life
needs to be secured by a government that
brings that Force
under some kind of objective control
now look I'm not defending existing
governments
unfortunately our institutions are being
corrupted they will maybe co-opt from
the beginning or at least had the seeds
of that corruption from the beginning
but they suddenly have been co-opted and
government has gotten worse over the
last hundred and something years
certainly in this country and in parts
of Europe
but the fact that institution has been
corrupted does not mean we erase it we
reject it University is a corrupt
our Health Care system is corrupt we
don't reject health care and reject
universities we go in and fix them we
identify what's wrong we identify what
the problem is we identify the source of
the corruption and we eradicate the
source of the corruption
so government today is corrupt it's just
another gang
but
to throw it out completely rather than
figure out what's wrong
is in my view a disaster
the absence of government
the absence of a monopoly over the use
of force
is chaos it's violence it's Civil War
Force becomes a tool
for human interaction
it's not banished
as government should do
but it is embedded in the system it is
something to be negotiated it is
something to be facilitated between the
different agencies competing for your
dollar in your defense and to retaliate
in your name
not my name your name I am my own
how they resolve disputes has nothing to
do with rights
and everything you do with a power
struggle among them
it becomes War we are politique and we
can see how different entities negotiate
they negotiate until one party feels
strong enough to take over the other
party
Anarchy gives a new twist to the term
hostile takeover
is there any doubt that the guys with
the bigger guns the guys who are
convinced that they could dominate
would try to dominate
and isn't it better for us if our agency
has more people into it than fewer
people under it so even the consumers
would be supportive
and
you know whatever might get called as
rule of law or objective process
adjudication where does it come from
what kind of process brings it about
it's just a terms for kind of an aim all
of truce momentary truth
between rival gangs each ready to force
concessions on the other
and look
Anarchy exists today
in every place that government leaves a
little room for competing with it
you have Anarchy
government leaves spaces and things that
it bans it's how we get organized crime
cartels mafias
and yes it's competition between gangs
between the Mafia the cartels and the
government
being one of the gangs that is being in
competition
neighborhood gangs compete with one
another because the space the police
won't go in there so the space is being
left free for them to provide security
services to collect
you know
security funds to protect you protection
money
ongoing they have a truce until somebody
sees a small advantage and leaps and
takes over
I mean just go to the West Bank or the
Gaza Strip
in Israel in
what is not exactly Israel where Israel
has withdrawn in a sense and what you
get is yeah you've got a police force of
the PLO and a police post of Hamas and
they
they sometimes negotiate and most of the
time they shoot at each other and one
party usually wins and dominates a
particularly geographic area because
that's what happens to Anarchy it turns
into an authoritarian state
and then they control that particular
piece of geographic area
and they exclude the other
and in that sense
because we have not created an
institution that bothers the initiation
of force because we have an Institute it
created a an institution that banishes
for us
we legitimize its use
you're competing over it
we're protecting different interests
and you can always imagine a security
Force
that is protecting I don't know the
interests of minorities
I don't know those who hate abortions
and want to persecute the doctors who
have abortions I don't know what the
position of this audience whether got a
copyrights are but I'm sure there's
disagreement uh well my agency wants to
protect crappie whites and Brian's
agency she doesn't want to protect
copyrights what do we do half of a
copyright we negotiate sometimes
sometimes we do it what about sex with
children or any other horrific thing you
can think of
what if there's a specific agency
protecting the people who are willing to
engage in those activities and what if
they have big guns and you don't want to
mess with them because it's too
expensive and it's too costly
and you think there's adverse selection
sure
but the markets for adverse selection
type risks
you pay a higher premium a significant
higher premium so you get the defense
you need for the horrific acts that you
engage in
but it's all possible it's Anarchy
there's no objective standard law
there's no individual rights there's no
absolute protection of those rights
so what is right what are individual
rights
is now open the competition can be now
challenged in the so-called Marketplace
and there's a sense in which today's
political system is more similar to
Anarchy than it is
to proper capitalism
we have pressure groups gangs trying to
get their way in yes you you know some
of its money some of its votes but the
point is that our whites are not
protected we as individuals
force is not banished from our society
it's competed over by all these pressure
groups in our political system trying to
take stuff away from us trying to take
our Liberty away from us
we're much closer to Anarchy today than
we are to True freedom and to True
capitalism
democracy is uh you know you you do
whatever you want to your neighbor
provided your gang is bigger than his
bigger in terms of size
Anarchy you do whatever you please do
and they ever provide you your gang is
stronger more powerful than his same
principle
see I'm almost out of time all right
look
I know there's a whole literature
that tries to explain how all this could
work under Anarchy
I get it
I you know it's a it's a fascinating uh
fascinating intellectual endeavor
but it's quite to quote unrand
it's naive floating abstractions or in
my vocabulary
rationalistic fantasy
in reality in this world
Anarchy leads to violence war Civil War
it's a complete disaster thank you
[Applause]
15 minutes for the negative take it away
Brian
capitalism would be a complete disaster
for Humanity it's my opponent your own
Brooke who is was the one who requested
the strong resolution not me still if I
was debating a normal economically
literate human being before a normal
economically literate audience I would
be worried
fortunately my opponent is a pro
opponent of Iran's objectivism and this
is the Soho Forum so we all agree on
some basic principles of how markets
work most notably rational self-interest
plus free competition plus reputation
normally yields excellent results for
both consumers and producers since Ein
Rand and your own Brooke Embrace this
principle they are sanguine about what
Libertarians call menarchy a society
where government provides nothing except
to quote John galt's speech in Atlas
Shrugged the police to protect you from
criminals the Army to protect you from
foreign Invaders and the courts to
protect your property and contracts from
breach of fraud by others to settle
disputes by rational rules according to
objective law
right now let's imagine a glorious
future where minarchy sweeps the world
here is my question for Brooke when
menarchy sweeps the world will it be a
complete disaster for Humanity if
multiple independent countries continue
to exist
if you answer yes you're obviously wrong
before 1945 you might have argued with
some plausibility the world government
is the only way to prevent World War III
now we know better having multiple
independent countries isn't a complete
disaster for Humanity even in the
philosophically corrupt horribly status
world of today indeed there is now a
long list of adjacent countries where
the probability of violent conflict is
near zero the U.S and Canada Norway and
Sweden even students of History dropped
your jaws
France and Germany
so what if you don't answer yes to will
it be a complete disaster for Humanity
if multiple independent countries
continue to exist you're stuck with no
and once you say no the next obvious
question is under minor key will it be
complete disaster for Humanity if the
world has a lot of small independent
countries if you say yes I'll respond
why if you say no you've already
accepted something that is functionally
equivalent to one prominent version of
anarcho-capitalism
the version I have in mind a society
where businesses contractually acquire
sizable tracts of land then provide
police courts and so on as part of the
package deal when conflict spills over
their borders they adjudicate their
disputes much as the United States and
Canada do today
if you object the stronger business will
just forcibly impose its will in the
weaker business you've got to explain
why the U.S doesn't forcibly impose its
will on Canada which it obviously does
not for a great great many reasons most
notably a
both sides morally opposed using
military force to resolve marginal
disputes B peaceful diplomacy works
tolerably well C the cost of blood
should exceeds the gain even for the
winner
now you could definitely argue that
having lots of small countries in
America's world is somewhat inconvenient
still if you think minarchy would be a
big improvement over the status quo the
net effect of moving from the world of
today to a minarcus world with
inconveniently small countries remains a
major Improvement and a major
improvement over the blatantly
non-disaster status quo is no disaster
can you really say that
anarcho-capitalism and menarchy with
lots of small countries are equivalent
there's only one notable difference
unlike governments businesses under
anarchical capitalism have to acquire
all their land through voluntary
contracts with individual Property
Owners no eminent domain no equivocation
between democracy and volunteerism the
difference is in nozick's word
historical did the system arise in a
morally exemplary way exemplary way
functionally however it doesn't matter
once established this version of undergo
capitalism and menarchy with lots of
small countries work the same way
now what about regular
anarcho-capitalism where people get
personal subscriptions to police courts
and so on instead of buying a package
deal from the real estate developer once
you can see that lots of small monarchic
countries can peacefully resolve their
cross-border disputes we can go further
the borders don't have to be
geographical they can be organizational
right now for example if two customers
of the same insurance company get into a
car accident the insurance company
handles the dispute internally
if two customers of different Insurance
some company companies get into an
accident the two Insurance canopies
handle the dispute contractually the
economically illiterate will insist the
companies will never agree they'll fight
it out in court to The Bitter End in the
real world however the insurance
industry has developed intricate systems
of adjudication that keep all almost all
of their disputes out of the
dysfunctional government courts a
regular anarcho-capitalism would work
the same way if two parties who dispute
subscribe to the same Protection Agency
the agency handles the dispute
internally otherwise the two agencies
handle the dispute contractually the
economically illiterate will insist the
agencies will never agree they'll fight
it out on the streets to The Bitter End
but in an established anarcho-capitalist
Society this makes about as much sense
as worrying that Sweden will become a
dictatorship and invade Norway
which speaks brings us to the big
question of why Sweden won't become a
dictatorship and invade Norway
because for most of its history Sweden
was a dictatorship and did repeatedly
invade Norway
here's my answer to this big question
suppose that in the year 1200 A.D a
Swede gave a speech advocating democracy
and calling for Perpetual peace with
Norway I submit that all of the other
Vikings would have laughed at his
naivete they would have laughed at the
idea of democracy if the strongest at
yarl doesn't win the election he'll just
murder the thinner and take over
and they would have laughed at the idea
of Perpetual peace with Norway but never
the Norwegians say they'll invade at the
first a sign of a weakness
and in 1200 A.D The Laughing Vikings
would have been correct when most people
expect dictatorship and War dictatorship
and War are stable and anyone who
expects anything else seems crazy
today however imagine that the prime
minister of Sweden gave a speech
advocating dictatorship and calling for
an invasion of Norway not only were the
other swedes laugh at him they'd assume
he was trying to make them laugh if the
Prime Minister persisted he would be
peacefully removed from Power the lesson
in a society where most people expect
democracy and peace democracy and peace
are stable and anyone who expects
anything else seems crazy
so what
if you claim that integral capitalism
would be a complete disaster for
Humanity if it were tried today like
right now I fully agree
but the problem isn't that
anarcho-capitalism fails to provide good
incentives or the system logically
collapses into gang Warfare the problem
is expectations moving from democracy to
stable undergo cap or removing from
stable democracy to stable
interco-capitalism is like moving from
stable dictatorship to stable democracy
shifting expectations is very hard but
the problem is the transition not the
destination
depressing kind of the good news is that
once we get to monarchy the last step to
anarcho-capitalism is minuscule I'm
going to end by showing you how
minuscule
under monarchy government provides
dispute resolution rule formation and
enforcement many even claim that some or
all these functions must be a Government
monopoly yet none of these functions are
monopolies even in the status world of
today and most of what government does
could easily be offloaded to the private
sector especially when the private
sector flourishes in the Glorious light
of laissez-faire
dispute resolution even today you don't
need government to resolve most disputes
if you allow binding arbitration binding
private arbitration almost everyone with
a contractual relation will eagerly opt
out of the court system if Government
courts declared we don't handle disputes
between people with contractual
relations you should have included an
arbitration Clause even more people will
opt out you near the final frontier When
government judges say your total
stranger is fined will appoint an
arbitrator goodbye
rule formation even today private
arbitrators make their own rules the
main limit no rule arbitration is truly
binding because governments can and will
overrule you if displeased under
menarchy binding arbitration would have
free reign and government lawmakers
would have almost nothing left to do
enforcement even today private
arbitrators enforce their own rulings
the reputation ostracism and bonding if
you don't pay your bills the main
sanction is just a bad credit rating
under minarchy again arbitrators and
everyone else could use these sanctions
freely the final Frontiers When
government courts say you signed a
binding arbitration contract that allows
them to jail you I have no jurisdiction
almost everyone in this room is used to
arguing for radical free market policies
almost everyone in this room knows the
standard inventory of status objections
though I'm eager to answer your
objections I think you can answer most
of them yourselves using arguments
you've already used a hundred times in
other contexts
if you think adults should have the
right to inject as much heroin as they
want and deny the results will be a
disaster for Humanity you shouldn't lose
sleep over adults right to sign fully
binding arbitration contracts
in the nature of government Iran called
Anarchy a floating abstraction but then
claimed that intercocapitalism was even
worse
one cannot call this Theory
contradiction in terms sentences
obviously devoid of any understanding of
the terms competition and government nor
can one call it a floating abstraction
since it is devoid of any contact with
or reference to reality and cannot be
concretized at all not even roughly or
approximately
since you've read Atlas Shrugged you
know Ein Rand is wrong
why because Ein Rand herself concretized
anarcho-capitalism with great clarity
remember galt's Gulch rand's Utopia of
greed here's how super Banker Midas
Mulligan explained it
we are not a state here not a society of
any kind we're just a voluntary
Association of men held together by
nothing but every man's self-interest I
own the valley and I sell the land to
others when they want it judge
narangonset is to act as our arbitrary
in case of disagreements he hasn't had
to be called upon as yet
they say that it's hard for men to agree
you'd be surprised how easy it is when
both parties hold it's their moral
absolute that neither exists for the
sake of the other and that reason is
their only means of trait
fortunately Rand asked too much you
don't need enthusiastic support to
sustain a political system even
reluctant fatalism will do
democracy becomes stable once most
people expect it to be stable minarchy
will be stable once most people expect
it to be stable anarcho-capitalism will
be stable once most people expect it to
be stable if and when they do there will
be no disaster for Humanity just the
second Renaissance thank you
five minutes to repuddle uh take away
Aaron
so it's interesting the examples being
used I you know this idea of uh of
Nations peacefully dealing with one
another when there is expectation of
Nations seems both a historical
and weird for the time given what's
going on between Russia and Ukraine
right now who would have thought just
very recently
that on in Europe there would be a major
land war in which thousands thousands of
uh of people
soldiers and Innocents uh lay dead
so yes I I believe multiple countries
would exist should exist
do I believe it will always be stable
and always peaceful no not necessarily
why one of the reasons I believe one of
the reasons why a country should have a
government should have a military force
that is able to protect its own citizens
from those of other countries that might
not share in values oh where the values
will have shifted that happens too
a stable Sweden might not be so stable
in a few years just think of the changes
just to take a issue buy-in is very good
on uh that we say just think of the
shift in Sweden on the issue of
immigration and how dramatic it has
happened in a fairly short period of
time
so countries change
the status quo changes
and one could could one imagine the
swedes and the Norwegians going to war
hard today but not impossible not
impossible at all
so I I don't get this illusion to other
countries it is absolutely true
that
if I you know if you have a piece of
land and you Institute law on the piece
of land and you Institute Security on
that piece of land then you're
instituting a government on that piece
of land so yeah corporations buying
large stacks of land and each having
their own government is government it's
not Anarchy
whether that is a good thing or a bad
thing put aside but it certainly is not
an okay
let's take the insurance examples and
the private security examples and
dispute resolutions examples I mean all
all these yeah they happen
people resolve disputes all the time
privately
in a system of government
in a system with it is
a the law
where there is an understanding of what
that law you know stands for within the
framework provided by a you know
reasonably good system of law that we
have today
lots of private things can't happen
that's the beauty of setting up an
objective system of law yes under such a
system there would be some dispute
resolutions some private arbitrations
but there will also be
circumstances where people don't agree
where private resolution is not possible
with private resolution deteriorates
into violence and what you need an
impartial
objective arbitrator to step in
and to be the ultimate Authority
with regard to these disputes
Justice also requires retribution it
requires going out and finding the
murderer
that is a tricky tricky activity
it's a tricky activity under any
circumstances but when you have multiple
police forces multiple system of
governance multiple agencies the idea
that they all can resolve
to not have collateral damage in
retribution is I think again more of a
fantasy than anything else
but what about Gold's Gulch
now it is true
there is one circumstance where I can
imagine and you know I might be
excommunicated for this but I can
imagine
Anarchy Anarchy walking right and that's
where everybody agrees
there are no criminals nobody ever has
an inclination to do anything wrong a
Gold's Gulch where everybody who is
there has been pre-screened a million
times by gold himself and by everybody
else yes you know if you can create a
community
with friends I've had friends that have
gone really really bad but you know with
people you really really trust and are
going to sustain it because it's in a
novel after all so they're going to stay
100 more throughout then yes you can
imagine such a scenario where you don't
need a police
but in any other circumstances
we need a government
we need
I see a blank piece in front of it uh
with no time
we need a an ultimate arbitrator uh for
for disputes like this and and a
objective applier of Retribution thank
you
thank you
hmm
so there's a couple of big problems with
the argument that Iran is giving
probably the fundamental one is there's
just a pile of tautological thinking we
hear a lot of talk about how you need to
have an objective neutral Arbiter well
where do we find that in the real world
nowhere and never
so just repeating that we're going is
the the Arbiter is going to be neutral
objective so on it solves nothing the
sensible approach is always comparative
in saying which of these two system is
actually more prone to problems and this
is where we actually have to get
empirical we can't just sit here and use
words in order to feel good about
ourselves and to feel good about our
prospects what is this government that
is supposed to be so objective and
reliable the import the impartial
Arbiter what government is the impartial
Arbiter of what happens on Earth right
now not the United States right
right now just over there again there's
also a lot of talk things like banishing
force like forces never banished it's
always possible for it to go wrong Iran
himself is saying you think your best
friend in the world's fine and then he
goes crazy on you all right so you got
that problem with the countries too
there is no way of locking in through
computer programming a neutral impartial
Arbiter and saying all right we got that
problem solved rather you are dealing
with flawed human beings all the time
and yes things can go from being
seemingly perfectly fine to being quite
bad
uh that said I will still say that there
is such a thing as social science and
there's also more importantly a thing
called betting and if you don't believe
that the peacefulness of Norway and
Sweden is super likely to continue for a
long time I will take your money because
it is going to continue for a long time
I will do a bet on a Century right now I
guess it'll have to be collected by our
heirs but either way it'll be an account
there are some facts the social world
that are so reliable that while yes we
can imagine them changing it would be
nothing short of a miracle for the U.S
to invade Canada can you even imagine
what would have to happen for that to
occur it's a crazy idea which shows that
just because you have the upper hand in
terms of physical force does not mean
that you are actually going to use it
nor the other side has no hope but to go
and build up a defense if you're on
we're right Canada would be have a civil
long ago have adopted a secret nuclear
program to deter the U.S because they
would say well what is all this a boot
right the U.S could crush us at any
second the only thing that would
possibly keep them to keep them in order
is nuclear weapons but fortunately
cooler heads prevailed and the Canadians
realize no I think that's the one thing
that might mess it up
the one thing that might mess up
relations with the U.S would be if we
tried to defend ourselves that would
make them upset that would make them
worried we will rather be causing the
problem that we're trying to avoid
all right uh let's see oh yes on the
point of real politic this is one where
your own makes a great Point throughout
most of human history this story that
whoever is stronger is going to just use
their strength and take over it's not
exactly true but there seemed to be a
lot of truth to it and then we have the
two World Wars which seem to further
confirm this ugly story and then after
1945 Miracles started happening we have
lasting peace between France and Germany
it's not quite as unlikely to go to war
as normally in Sweden but again I will
bet you at 101 odds against any kind of
a series War for between France and
Germany this is the first time this has
been imaginable in like a thousand years
now what's going on and this is of
course there are so many other country
pairs basically every country in the EU
you can be confident they will not
engage in any kind of serious war with
any other country in the EU maybe some
proxy war far away but that's about it
right this is something that is
historically unprecedented but is a big
fact about the social world how did it
happen and I say the story is that
change in expectations if any country in
the EU said let's go attack some other
country in the EU they would first be
laughed at or laughed with and then
laughed at and then people would say
this person's a lunatic let's get him
out of power like and you and if like it
seems hard to believe we could have
gotten into such a great equilibrium but
so we did right so it is not actually
historical now if you say there's some
bad countries in the world yeah there
are some but the fact that we have
gotten as far as we have since 1945
means that there is room for immense
optimism about what the future of
humanity is you know Stephen pinker's
Enlightenment now I think it is a lot
more likely the whole world will be like
the EU in 200 years then we will go back
to the world of 1800 or 1900 in terms of
how foreign policy works it is just very
difficult in the modern world to get
away with using for successfully and not
just because of the hegemony of the
United States but for all those reasons
that I mentioned right so normally
diplomacy is just a better way of doing
it and is worse even for the aggressor
itself
right now finally remember it's Iran
that asks for the really strong
resolution he's the one who said he's
going to argue it's a complete disaster
of humanity and he ends up by saying how
do we know that Norway won't evade
Sweden all right we don't know with
absolute certainty but that's a far cry
from the resolution he's supposed to be
defending thank you very much
[Applause]
uh thank you uh yeah thanks yeah we now
go to the Q a portion of the evening uh
there is a microphone and you can line
up to ask your questions we're going to
pose a rule this evening in terms of
time that you each uh yeah and and uh
and uh Brian have the opportunity to ask
each other two questions at any time uh
perhaps you want to just get the
audience uh but uh to ask questions but
Brian do you want to exercise that
option yeah and do you want exercise
option to ask a question at this point
no
no no you're speaking like the audience
after a while and then do it yeah
um I I'm gonna access moderators to ask
a uh a particular question of Brian uh
we do uh your argument is that and I
gather it's empirically valid that
despite all the wars we see uh Warfare
has diminished despite the fact that the
U.S
did sponsor an invasion of Cuba that has
invaded a lot of countries killed
millions of people our country in
particular
you're still pointing to this as
optimistic because the US did not have
had to invade Canada so you think the
trends are on your side is that
basically your argument despite all the
Bloodshed that has existed and all the
invasions the U.S has sponsored things
have improved tremendously if you were
to tell people in 1945 what the world
what Europe is like today they would
have laughed in your face I think they
would have said yeah France and Germany
or Perpetual peace more likely of world
war three in ten years and honestly in
1945 I think I would have agreed with
them but events have shown that's very
wrong uh you've got pinker's whole story
about the pacification of humanity of
course it's not going to happen
uniformly and there are still some bad
things that are going on but I think it
is totally reasonable to think that in
the next 100 200 years that the whole
world is going to look like the West in
terms of the extremely low probability
of any kind of actual serious Warfare
between them comment from you again on
that yeah I mean I don't disagree here
really with Brian but that is I I do
think the world is amazingly peaceful
and it is an in Maine's achievement of
the ideas of Freedom that led to kind of
the the creation of governments that for
the most part protect individual rights
and as and part of the consequence of
that has been uh you know a respect for
individuals not only in your own country
but in other countries as well and as a
consequence yeah I mean I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna bet on the odds of Sweden
Norway but to say that it's impossible
under circum circumstances and again I
don't see the parallel I'm quite willing
to concede that we have multiple
countries and those countries
particularly if those countries are
countries that respect individual rights
are going to exist in peace even when
one has overwhelming superiority for us
even when one has overwhelming
superiority of us but
that does not extrapolate to the kind of
conflicts that exist in the same
geographic area if you have multi if you
have you know geography matters space
matters we live in space and the the the
potential for conflicts a number of
conflicts the kind of conflicts that are
potentially happening within a
particular geographic area is Multiplied
exponentially as compared to what
happens between countries and I I think
it's a it's a it's an issue of both
degree and kind it's a completely
different type of of scenario the
smaller the countries the more police
agencies have to interact of course you
get down to really tiny countries they
will be interacting all the time and I
mean it's not it's not the case in the
U.S that when you have smaller
jurisdictions you see their police
fighting it out more often it basically
doesn't happen yeah well that was a
question I mean Europe the European
countries are in the same geographical
area Canada North America Mexico they're
in the same area driven across France
it's a big place it's a big place yeah
Luxembourg and Lichtenstein who knows
why they exist exactly but yes they're
very small but generally these are Big
spaces uh countries governments uh you
know I have no problem in multiple it's
good to have multiple because it's
important that government Reign Over a
particular geographic area that's where
the law applies uniformly on that area
if on the same geographic area you have
multiple systems of law you're asking
for conflict you are you're you're
defining conflict into the system and
this is why it has to be a disaster let
me just one correction the the the topic
for this debate was genes not mine so it
was not my formulation my formulation
was something like and our capitalism is
a contradiction attorney can't have both
of them I must exercise moderators
prerogative
to declare that every debate at the soul
Forum every word is signed off by each
debater I have it as a matter of record
that both Debaters including yaron
signed off on the wording we did it
unacceptable therefore you must stick to
the terms of the contract in order to
avoid violent conflict in it okay so uh
you need to come to the after party and
see how this is resolved so can I use
one of my questions now Gene well I'm
sorry may I use one of my questions
so you're wrong on the one hand you're
saying that it's fine to have multiple
countries but on the other hand all
these dire predictions of well what will
happen if one country with greater force
goes and wants to do something the other
one disagrees that exists whenever
there's multiple countries the only
answer it seems like you've really got
is well there'll be an impartial Arbiter
of there being a super government but it
doesn't sound like you want that either
so again like all of these predictions
of Doom hold like if you think think
they are likely they hold anytime
there's multiple governments and we
think they're unlikely then why are you
so confident about interco-capitalism
being a complete disaster for Humanity
well I said that earlier I think that
the protection of individual rights
resides in a particular geographic area
and while different governments might
interpret the protection of individual
rights differently it affects the people
in that geographic area one of the
reasons why I love open immigration and
I pro-open immigration is the ability of
people to choose what kind of exact
regime they want their protection of
individual rights to to hold under so
they can move from country to Country
and and right but they also one kind of
you know armed robbers go from one
country you'll come back and then the
first country says we don't recognize
what do you do
I missed the question sorry I was
thinking about my answer and you know so
like usual okay some French bank robbers
going to Germany rob it go back to
France and then say Oh we do not rate
our government will protect us all right
and maybe yes that happens all the time
right we do have also bank robbers you
go to countries that don't have really
actually what normally happens is France
says oh we will protect we hand them
over the Germans yes right and that's
and that's the way they do business yes
and they they've got deals but again
you're ignoring the idea that there is a
one rule under one system what if
Germany what if Germany decided that it
was going to protect bank robbers any
and and it had a system that it was
going to protect by gloves and any bank
robbers who left France came to Germany
were going to be protected what if in
the same geographic area you had a
insurance agency that basically said
women showing bank robbers will take
your money we'll take a cut of
everything you do and we are going to
protect you and we'll we'll apply we'll
apply force in order to protect you from
the consequences how do you resolve that
is is one ultimately one Defense Agency
is going to have to impose itself on the
other look this is the same story
friends in Germany like if France really
didn't like Germany protecting some
French bank robbers do you know what
happened they would make a strongly
worded letter and then that would and
then at first nothing would happen and
then condition conditions would
gradually rate normally of course the
other side would say you know we really
shouldn't be making such a big deal
about these stupid bank robbers let's
hand them back over and that's how it
actually happens that's how the US and
Canada deal each other yes it is
negotiation but you know note this is
not tautology I don't just say that
these are rational countries and
therefore we'll handle an irrational way
I say this is what really happens with
real places in the real world you know
and by the way one other thing
because it doesn't happen in other
places right these are these are a bunch
of crummy cells or democracies that you
and I both despise you're on how can you
say such good things about these
countries they're terrible
okay it's in Germany in the United
States and Canada these are crummy
social democracies
they're a disgrace yeah
relative relativity history we still
live with the best governments in the in
in human history and the religion
relative to their moral obligations we
both know that they are criminals I
think they're terrible I think we could
uh these guys could go at it for another
couple of hours because they don't read
too much Gene they're both I'm sorry
they're both very Lively Minds uh but I
wanna I Wanna Give the audience a chance
to ask a question please frame it like a
question and don't have to identify
yourself if you're addressing the
question to a particular individual say
so go ahead take it away sir
which is it might be a very hard sell
but to make your job easier
oh okay good uh you want to completely
shrink government down to nothing which
is a very hard sell in my view to make
your job easier could you promote the
shrinking of government down to the
limited level Dr Brook is advocating
which you would need to do anyway and
then uh without mentioning Anarchy at
all once that limited government is
achieved
let it breathe for five years and then
at the end of that if you're still
dissatisfied then you can push for
Anarchy totally reasonable totally
reasonable look I'd be happy if we could
shrink government one percent
that would be amazing
people say what's the point of writing
your book saying that you should get rid
of all government funding for Education
say to give a little bit of Steal to
someone that doesn't want to increase
education funding
right so yeah like I'll take what I can
get honestly but conceptually the key
point is that if you did get down to
minarchy the last step to
anarcho-capitalism would be almost
nothing especially when you remember the
role of binding arbitration important
thing about binding arbitration is that
if we had it now that would almost be
the end of the regulatory State already
because guess what I can run a business
and my brother could be the arbitrator
and then no longer will any sex
harassment laws get enforced no longer
will any wage regulations be enforced no
longer any safety regulations being
forced if you're binding arbitration you
get around almost any existing voice
comment from you again coming good yeah
who's binding it that is the the who who
actually implements the decision of the
court if if the parties decide not at
the end of it to not agree with the
binding arbitration with the decision
there has to be it has to be somebody
who steps in and uses Force here and the
question is the question is I mean today
it exists today arbitration exists
because there is a final Authority there
is a final determinant of of of the use
of force and and the application of it
but in Anarchy it's just it I don't want
I don't I don't I don't want to go to
jail so actually not really I mean
here's the thing with binding
arbitration there's a really easy way to
make enforceable without government
which is everyone posts a big Bond and
that's where the damage has come out of
that means you don't even need to go to
the government in order to get it
enforced if you post a million dollar
Bond and then the arbitrator says you
owe 500 000 you say I object like well
too bad we've already transferred 500
000 out of the account because you
signed it over to us should these are
easy in these uh in in only if it's only
monetary it's easy if it's smaller than
the million dollars it's easy yeah right
sure and and I have no doubt that
arbitration would exist under any system
much like this can be done in
arbitration I mean my point is that once
we get to monarchy a minute a monarchic
government is morally obliged to accept
binding arbitration contracts and once
they do that there's almost nothing for
them left to do and that point is like
so all you do is is deal with with
enforcing binding arbitration when one
side refuses to go along that's your job
that is not just like one percent of
what it currently does we're talking
about 0.0001 it's down to next it's not
clear that most people would want
binding arbitration there would be an
option of them to get the arbitration
done by the state there's no there's no
reason to believe by any arbitration
would see better because government's
incompetent it sucks governing
competitive sucks as the government we
have today that's not how government has
to be and there's absolutely no reason
why uh government couldn't provide that
arbitration it could be one option I
have no objection to shrinking
government as much as we can as long as
it is the ultimate Authority as long as
it is the ultimately in terms of use of
force in a particular geographic area
next question
all right my question Mike
no can you hear it yes sure my question
is for Brian it's uh the the first
conceptualization of anarcho-capitalism
where you have these small corporations
that occupy a certain territory it
sounds to me a lot like monarchy in a
very small form what's the difference
between this capitalist who owns this
area and then allows people to rent part
of it versus a king who has an area and
you know has has their their peasants on
the land
yeah I mean the big difference is just
who does it and who's going to actually
be good at doing this so uh in the real
world we see that when there's
competition between monarchies and
corporations corporations win
monarchies just aren't very good at
exist at doing anything in the modern
world other than maybe promoting tourism
or something like that
so yeah I mean in principle yes you
could have someone says I'm the king a
Barataria and you can go and move here
and be under my rule I don't think
that's likely to be a successful
business model because it doesn't work
in in almost any other industry that I
know of again other than maybe promoting
tourism a little bit
coming so so say if a corporation sets
up a census it's uh territory and says
come here and be a surf and and there
are people who go there you're fine with
that so so I mean So Gone Gone
individual rights who cares who cares
about individual rights who cares about
individual freedom and liberty well of
course as long as they did it quote
voluntarily they might be poor people
who don't have any other options they
come from the south and they they go as
long as you know that's fine violate
their rights freely as long as what
you realize this is the standard
complaint about of every leftist against
almost every job that low skilled people
get right
there's a difference I you know there's
only people like the difference is
there's a big difference there's a big
difference I think we understand between
uh you know becoming a slave and
becoming a a an employee uh there's a
big difference in how you're treated
there's a big difference in how your
rights are respected
um and the reality is that even if
people go there and become slaves who's
going to protect them who's why should
anybody protect them right they they
went there voluntarily the corporation
could change the law by the way and they
can change it and turn them into slaves
and who cares right so the principle of
individual rights doesn't exist under
Anarchy it doesn't exist property rights
are not being protected they're being
violated uh at the whim of the Monarch
the king I mean we might have monarchs
under under Anoka capitalism under the
corporation so the whole principle in
which freedom is founded the whole
principle in which individual liberty is
founded is trashed in the name of well
let's see maybe the corporation can make
a living maybe it won't maybe okay for
slavery is not economically viable
this is more this is more tonological
thinking of you're going comparing
actual corporations to a theoretically
ideal government if we're talking about
the real where you say how do you know
the government wants group people over
it's like yeah I don't uh now in the in
the case of the business model you're
talking about it's very similar to the
company town which has a very bad
reputation but as noted economic
historian price mischbeck has shown
company towns actually were fine
uh next question
so both of you can respond to this but
if I'm understanding Brian's argument
correctly you're saying that even though
most people think
anarcho-capitalism wouldn't happen here
today couldn't happen might be terrible
if it we try to force it right now that
it's conceivable because in 1200 the
Vikings couldn't conceive of democracy
but here we have it today so so
my
point though you know to question is
that
in 1200
even though the Vikings might not have
known about it there were historical
examples of democracies and republics
that had flourished and gotten along
peacefully with their neighbors right so
they had existed actually in 12 before
1200 well before 1200 but I don't know
of a single example of an
anarcho-capitalist Society ever right so
doesn't the fact that a narco-capitalism
has failed to reify anywhere in the
world in fact count massively against
the probability that it wouldn't be a
disaster is clear go ahead all right
yeah great question all right so David
Friedman if you were here we'll tell you
about all about Iceland I think he's
probably right about Iceland as being
darn close to enter her capitalism uh I
take his word for it but I don't speak
Icelandic so I'm not going to say I've
gone through the archives myself I would
actually just point to the not just
menarchy but cases where of private
arbitration private security we're we
see that we actually not only can we get
away from government law but there is
immense demand to get away from
government law because government law is
bad and people would rather deal with
something that is more efficiently
produced by the business Community now
by the way so my argument is not just
that people in 1200 didn't realize the
world could be really different
therefore my idea about how the world
could be really different is likely too
that would be a bad argument
um my so I am actually referring
specifically to literature on what are
the incentives under anarcho-capitalism
I didn't have time to go over them in
detail but uh you know it is out there I
mean and just to say like is it true is
it all expectations no there's sometimes
expectations Aren't Enough like if
everybody expects that everyone will
clean up the communal kitchen do you
know what happens the kitchen is filthy
because everyone says somebody else will
do it so I don't need to and then the
kitchen's filthy but on the other hand
if everybody expects that war is not
going to happen guess what then if you
push war you do seem like a crazy person
so again it is not just this very this
pretty lame argument that the things
have changed a lot therefore things
could change a lot in my direction uh
that would be just true but pretty
trivial uh but yeah rather what I say is
that is actually we can look at the
actual analysis the incentives
furthermore I think there are historical
examples that are very close but yeah
it's not going to be perfect but then
again guess what those Greek democracies
aren't such great examples of democracy
either and think you're wrong about the
piece right usual stories Athens was the
big aggressor in most of the Greek Wars
at the time
yeah two things one is if you're
interested in Iceland I would recommend
reading their sliding sagas as I did on
a visit to Iceland wow the brutality the
violence pretty amazing how Anarchy
deteriorated very quickly and people
killing each other's siblings and uh and
uh and and destroying each other's
property that's what happens in Anarchy
when you don't have uh any kind of any
kind of rule of law but
um David Friedman says it was 200 years
with a lower per capita murder rate than
the continental Europe I tend to believe
I'm super skeptical uh and again
read the stories read the stories as
icelandics write about their own period
of Anarchy and what they the stories
they tell about how it was I I think it
will be quite eye-opening in terms of
the the David Friedman story
um
had another point but it's gone so go
ahead next question uh just as a
demographic prediction from each debater
uh do you think a large portion of
objectivists nowadays perhaps a growing
portion are anarcho-capitalists since
completely consistent property rights
adherence presumably means you can't
steal from somebody and call it taxes
you can't regulate somebody and oh you
can't assault somebody and call it
regulation are they turning into a
narco-capitalists whether Ein Rand would
have liked it or not
um uh yeah and why don't you take that
question first yeah I would say by
definition no uh so I don't think you
could be an objectivist and an Alka
capitalist and indeed you know I meant
to say this during my talk but I think
an okay capitalism is a contradiction of
terms I don't think you have capitalism
and Anarchy at the same point in time
you're either an anarchist or capitalist
capitalism requires government as I try
to articulate uh so no I I I don't think
there are but you know then alcohol
capitalist as they call themselves
Community is the definitely growing a
lot of them were influenced by iron maid
I think Brian would be one of them right
so people who've been influenced by Iron
Band and are today and Uncle capitalist
there's a lot of them uh people who are
objectivists and anaka capitalists they
are none of uh you want to come in brand
or you want to wave you want to comment
no okay totally for Iran except on the
definition okay yeah all right next
question
thank you both for the debate I have a
question for Kaplan could you please
share your thoughts on how global trade
would function between an
anarcho-capitalist country and a
non-anarco-capitalist country in general
I'm concerned about the Practical
integration of an anarchical capitalist
country on a global scale
I mean honestly I would say that you're
likely to get a a great pacification of
the earth and they moved in a manicure
Direction before you're going to get
anarcho-capitalism anywhere once that is
the norm around the world that they are
countries are first of all Pacific and
second of all that most of them are at
least in general sympathy with these
ideas then one area going further I
think will get the same kind of
what's the right word uh the other the
same kind of sympathy and fellow
travelerhood that the Soviet Union got
from all the socialist sympathizing
countries in the world it's like well
they may be going a little too far maybe
a little crazy but they're Noble
idealists so again like the fear that
they would get attacked by others are
taken over like in the world where it's
likely to happen is I think really low I
mean you know worth pointing out the
Soviet Union did not actually suffer any
serious Invasion until the Nazis there
were some very feeble efforts to unseat
them but that was it and a lot of it was
these fifth columnists around the world
saying that it's a noble experiment give
it a chance
uh common again no no okay uh next
question
uh question for Kaplan which is how do
we guarantee that the conditions of
freedom from coercion exist without a
final Arbiter especially when you know
there's some decisions just should not
be on the table for example you should
not be allowed to be an organization
that allows child molestation and even
if some people a large number of people
think that's okay and you know there are
always going to be a large swath of
people that are vulnerable and not
capable of making decisions and
um and also like um
yeah like yeah well I guess answer that
one first all right so this is the real
world so there's no guarantees sorry
of course this this applies for both
governments and Anarchy how do we
guarantee there won't be any government
that goes and starves millions of their
own people oh whoops there were a bunch
of governments that did that there's
just no guarantees right so the only
thing that's sensibles to think about
comparative risk which system is likely
to have a lower risk uh this is one
where like I said if we are in a society
where most people think that
interco-capitalism will collapse then
guess what it's going to collapse right
on the other hand if we're in a world
where most people expect to be stable
then it will be stable how do we
guarantee there won't be any area that
allows anything bad we can't I mean like
so right now I actually I was just
hearing the story that in the 70s
Denmark legalized child pornography
and you know what the response to the
rest of the world was
nothing
all right so that's the real world like
there's just no guarantee sorry
so I think there should be guarantees
and I think that's what we should be
advocating by who World governments
anything in a particular geographic area
there should be guarantees or at least
that's what we should be striving for is
that it's to set up an ideal that
internally says they're going to be no
guarantees yeah if some people want to
molest children and they get a security
agency to protect them so be it then
when negating this fundamental principle
of individual rights this is why it's a
complete disaster this is why it's bad
for for Humanity that is in a particular
geographic area we should be striving
towards a system that does guarantee the
children are not molested now will some
children be molested yes will they be
prosecuted yes right so that is the kind
of system we want to achieve we want to
strive towards to set up a system which
we know if enough people pay enough
money they will be protected that is a
negation of the whole idea of human
flourishing and individual success and
Liberty yeah what would you think you
went to Costco and you said is this
product guaranteed and they said well
we're striving to guarantee it that's
the same as not guaranteeing all right
so yes I'm all in favor of making the
world better and doing a good job but to
me that's just empty promises and you've
got to do better than that if you
promised a guarantee which you can't but
capitalism this really is just like the
let's see in the movie Fargo when there
is the guy who like who's responsible
for having his wife kidnapped sorry to
give the movie away and then his
father-in-law says what guarantee do I
have of this money and he says the
guarantee is I guarantee you'll get it
back
it's not a guarantee so look this is
just the real world I'm not going and
expressing a blase or a different
attitude human suffering I am saying
don't make promises that you can't that
you can't actually back up because you
can't but that's the whole principle of
individual it's all principle of
individual rights the whole idea of a
government that protects individual
rights is to provide that guarantee
whether it's implemented and applied 100
but it that is the kind of system that
you want to build the kind of system
that that is defined in a sense of we
are going to protect
people's Liberty we are going to protect
people's individual rights and if you
set it up without that protection then
you're setting it up for a failure if
the standard is individual flourishing
okay yeah all right next question you
have a quick follow-up see me I'm sorry
I wish we could do that but we want to
give more people that the opportunity to
ask questions go ahead sir this is for
uh both uh Debaters uh one was one uh
method this has been suggested for
encouraging competition among provision
of Security is to allow districts to
secede from their historic uh States and
either go independent or join the
adjacent uh State uh Nation or state
government
um such should the United States be
allowed to secede from the British
Empire should Ukraine be allowed to
secede from the Soviet Union should
Crimea be allowed to secede from Ukraine
should Maine be allowed to secede from
the United States and go join Canada uh
would uh either of you go along with
that or do you think that well yeah
you've let off most of the time so uh
the right of secession should flood can
California secede from uh from the U.S I
said the only reason to succeed is if
you're moving to towards a a a a state
of Greater Freedom if you're moving
towards a state of Greater protection of
individual rights then I think you have
a way to seed but that way to secede is
relevant because nobody's going to let
California succeed that is it's not
going to be negotiated they're not going
to sit down and agree to it just like it
didn't happen uh with the United States
leaving Great Britain a war has to be
fought a war would be fought so
secession no no state in the in the U.S
is going to secede without a civil war
but uh Canada almost allowed Quebec to
secede that would have they would have
if the vote had gone the other way is
special
um
the only legitimate reason to secede is
to become more free to to become more
socialist then you're violating you're
violating the rights of your own
citizens by making them less free
through secession
I mostly agreed around there you're on
there actually I do not support
succession in general you got to show me
it's going to give you some incredible
benefits or else it's just a waste of
time uh next question
thank you my question is mainly directed
at Dr Kaplan although I would enjoy
hearing Dr Brooks uh thoughts on my
question which is Dr Kaplan I operate
from the premise that capitalism is a
political system and that politics is a
derivative of Ethics or morality
and if you are an advocate of capitalism
I wonder if you could explain uh
from where your moral basis or your
moral Foundation that you build on to be
an advocate of that political system
called capitalism thank you thank you so
much this is my chance to plug Mike
humor's Incredible Book the problem of
political Authority
which answers the question uh what he
says is that we have presumptive
individual rights of the libertarian
kind if it would lead to total disaster
then it's okay to violate those rights
normally that doesn't happen and that's
why it's important to understand social
science to see is it really true that it
would be disastrous to go and follow
these policies and if it's not then I go
back to the default of individual rights
um uh comment from you yaren and
unfortunately that's going to have to be
the last question this is good okay last
question from you then sir go ahead uh
Dr Brooke uh you are an advocate of
monarchism but you acknowledge you hear
me uh you acknowledge that uh States
exist in a world of different nations uh
and Dr Kaplan uh you uh uh describe the
world as an inarco capitalist world but
I believe at some point you said that
ideally we would have a world of a lot
of uh menarchist States perhaps like a
hopian a thousand liechtensteins so are
in fact both of you saying the same
thing and this actually isn't even a
debate oh wow okay
I'm afraid that that question is gonna
have to stand but uh
okay this this non-debate uh uh uh will
have to conclude its q a uh section we
have now go to the summations and of
course you can address that question if
you'd like uh yeah yeah and you're the
affirmative so you go first in the
summation five minutes for summary take
it away Aaron
foreign
thank you so God it went dark suddenly
uh so uh no this is an actual debate the
differences between us are not whether
we agree that there would be uh
competing governments over separate
Geographic territories I think we agree
with that uh the disagreement is whether
such a competition can exist in a
particular geographic area where the uh
the sovereignty overlaps between the
different uh security agencies and I
think one is uh different sovereignties
is the way in which the world would
function and I hate the term monochism
um I I prefer to consider myself an
advocate for limited government for
limited by the principle of individual
rights we government only protects
individual rights and nothing else I
believe that is what capitalism means
that is that is uh that is the essence
of capitalism that is it is a system
that protects individual whites not
leaves it up to maybe the security
agencies will do it and maybe they won't
maybe they'll arbitrate it appropriately
maybe they won't but where the system is
built geared towards
the resolution of those disputes based
on a principle
on the principle of individual
sovereignty on the principle of the
sanctity of every individual in his
right to his own life
so I think that is what brings
objectivity to the system it has a
principle that guides decision making
that guides the resolution of disputes
that are bound to arise even if we're
all friendly
so
the system we have today
is indeed a disaster system a system of
gangs and horrible and yet
you know in spite of this we live
probably in a time of of of Greater uh
of Greater Prosperity certainly of uh to
some extent greater Liberties than ever
before
greater freedom
at least in certain Dimensions than ever
before and all of this is because
the concept of individual rights has
been discovered and applied
fraud
but it in a flawed way and therefore the
the system that we have today is
dramatically flawed
but we have an opportunity to really fix
it we have an opportunity to actually
make
a truly free Society but to do that we
have to abide by what makes a society
free and that is the abolition of force
and the institution of this principle
of this guarantee we guarantee that each
individual
has his rights and those rights will be
protected by government Anarchy does not
do this
Anarchy makes it all negotiable rights
are negotiable truth is negotiable facts
are negotiable
Anarchy is a demolition of everything
that has been built up to reach where we
are today
it is worse than a distraction
it subverts our efforts to actually
change the institution that exists the
institution of government to make it
better as Brian said we want to move
towards Freedom yes we want to move
towards Freedom every movement towards
freedom is necessary
but to do that we have to have an idea a
concept of what that freedom is where
we're moving towards where we are
heading and what our ideal is and that
ideally is has to be centered around the
principle that makes this government
function even half decently today
so
by advocating
for a system that indeed demolishes the
principle of individual rights
demolishes I think the principle of
private property
we are undermining our efforts to bring
about greater Liberty and greater
freedom to the world
I think the more we Advocate the more we
we promote the idea of of uh of Anarchy
the more we promote ideas and
philosophical foundations that undermine
the idea the very idea of individual
freedom in individual liberty so it's
not just that I think that in our
capitalism is a disaster when it happens
a complete and utter disaster but I
believe it's advocacy today is a
disaster in terms of our ability to move
the goals forward to move us towards
greater individual Freedom greater
individual rights and towards a real
capitalist society which I think is
possible
but the work needs to be done and the
work is intellectual work and
educational work thank you
[Applause]
all right
all right so let's just go back to that
shared principle that I think almost
everyone in this room agrees with you
know rational self-interest plus free
competition plus reputation normally
equals excellent results for both
consumers and producers right the
strange thing is though Iran I believe
would totally be on board the principle
you don't see any sign that he's using
this principle when thinking about this
issue instead what we've got are
honestly a lot of tautologies like he
keeps telling us that government gives
us guarantees government doesn't give us
any guarantees in the real world you
could say we should Aspire for a
guarantee all right but guess what
aspiring for a guarantee isn't a
guarantee so again it really all comes
back to comparative risk and looking at
things empirically right now it is
striking to me that he really didn't
seem to want to talk about the empirics
and especially didn't want to talk about
the actual failures of all known
existing governments and how
disappointing they really are you just
have this idea that existing governments
in the west are just flawed versions of
what we're talking about yeah that's
really nice
it's very charitable in fact it's
altruistic in terms of how charitable it
is to existing governments existing
governments like barely care about
individual rights at all or if they do
it what they care about is their
resilient notion which is primarily
about positive rights that's the main
thing they care about and they are super
happy to go and trample normal negative
capitalist rights in order to go and
guarantee all the things that they
really care about so-called which by the
way aren't guarantees either
right so whereas when I was going over
my story I was trying to appeal to these
basic ideas rational self-interest plus
free competition plus reputation that
reputation part is important when Iran
talks about what is to go and stop
someone from saying come to my area and
then enslaving them yeah that's
reputation that does that that's why
when we had come you know with a company
town you might say this company says
come over to our town and I'll give you
a great job but once you're out in the
company town you spend all your money
maybe they will go and then go and offer
you one tenth of what they promised you
uh yeah that's theoretically possible
but guess what Market forces reputation
competition self-interest these are
things that actually stopped it which by
the way are a much better guarantee than
government saying I guarantee it
way better now in this question of
multiple governments
like I'm very glad that Iran and Mitch
that under minarchy we can have multiple
governments but once you admit that
there are many big implications this
namely that a lot of his complaints
about anarchical capitalism in fact I
think all of his complaints about
anarcho-capitalism still exist if we
have a multiple independent governments
a specialty or small independent
governments what do you do if there's
one agency that goes and protects child
molesters all right what do you do if
one government protects child molesters
yeah that's tough for any system it's
like all right well do we go and do a
trade embargo on them do we attack them
do we try to assassinate their leaders
this is where it's like hmm yeah all
those Solutions have a bunch of problems
don't they gee what are we going to do
and you know why the question is hard
because it's in the real world it's not
a bunch of tautologies where we use
words to go and solve problems that
actually have to be solved by actions
all right now the last Point uh this
minuscule step from Anarchy to
anarcho-capitalism
like I said I do think that it does
count as anarcho-capitalism if you have
a bunch of very small
private landed landowners who go and
bundle police and courts with their
services this is just like a homeowner
association of the of the key element of
being a government really is the people
that don't consent can still be made to
join that's what actually distinguishes
governments from private organizations
the real world is that governments
violate unanimous consent right right
and yeah everybody knows the United
States was not founded on unanimous
consent right like Sandra spooners
constitutional Authority right you
should read it if you haven't now in
terms of the social science my point
here is once we are at monarchy already
then the difference between that and
actually full-blown interco-capitalism
is very slight most obviously because
America government would have to protect
would have to respect binding
arbitration and there are very strong
reasons for people to agree to binding
arbitration just to go and reduce
administrative costs if you're going and
applying for a job and you say hey I
don't want to sign this binding
arbitration Clause like huh you sound
like you're going to go and sue us in
the government courts so yeah we
probably don't really want you as
employee and on the other end's employee
you might say gee why do you want me to
sign the binding arbitration Clause what
are you planning on doing to me and
again the obvious answer is oh yes
reputation is going to protect me right
so like I said I think everyone in this
room has had debates of this kind many
times over and I think that if you apply
not my prince but your own principles in
a slightly different context you will
wind up agreeing with me and not your
own thank you very much
[Applause]
Jane uh please open the voting
again anico capitalism would definitely
be a complete disaster for Humanity yes
no or undecided I have in my hand the
Soho Forum Tootsie Roll which I'm going
to toss to the winner once the winner is
announced again we are of course hosting
the after party just two blocks uptown
at 55 great Jones Street follow me
follow the crowds unfortunately Brian
has Promises to Keep tomorrow morning
and has to take catch a cast to catch a
plane I'd love to party with all you
guys but I've got to run sorry but
unfortunately I'll buy anyone here lunch
if you come to Fairfax yes okay
that's uh that's a binding offer and uh
and
um yeah but yarn will be there with his
wife he's a heck of a Charming guy quite
friendly quite approachable and uh and
uh over there yes and well and that's
what I sincerely believe I've known both
of these guys for a long time and
they're both they're both great guys uh
I want to announce as well uh that we
have other debates planned October 18th
will be our next debate uh that will be
a debate about electric vehicles uh Mark
Mills versus Rosario fortuno and Mark
Mills will defend the resolution a
little wordy but again you've got to
negotiate every word and make sure both
sides agree to the wording between now
and 2035 electric vehicles in the
consumer Market will likely disappoint
environmentalists by remaining a product
bought mainly by the well-heeled
minority that's Mark Mills versus
Rosario fortuno on Tuesday November 14th
we're going to have a debate about
artificial intelligence Susan Smith
versus jobs landgreave she will defend
the resolution artificial intelligence
poses a threat to the survival of
humanity that must be actively addressed
that's Tuesday November 14th Sunday
December 17th we're going to have a
matinee a 3 P.M matinee on Sunday
December 17th and that will be a debate
between law professor Kate clinic and
epidemiologist J bhattacharya the
resolution that Cape Clinic well I think
you will will defend will be worded as
follows the making of national internet
policy was hindered rather than helped
by the July 4th Federal Court ruling
that restricted the Biden
administration's Communications with
social media platforms as many of you
know Jay barucharia who will be taking
the negative on that resolution was one
of the key plaintiffs in that Federal
Court ruling and that's St John's law
professor Kate clinic will defend the
resolution uh January uh we uh that this
will be uh on uh actually on January
29th we're going to take a long break
after the new year and this resolution
will read government must play a role in
fostering scientific and technological
progress by funding basic research they
taking the affirmative will be Anthony
Mills of the American Enterprise
Institute taking the negative will be
Terence Keeley author of the economic
laws of scientific research that will be
in late January Jane how are we doing on
the voting it looks as though the
results are coming in drumroll please
okay well uh uh the uh the yes went from
38.4 to 48.1 percent picked up
10.7 points uh to picking up 10.7 points
very close the no went from 33 to 41
picking up a little over eight points a
little over a two point margin in favor
of the yes so the the Tootsie Roll goes
to Young
but
congratulations about I have to say I
have to say that a two-point margin is
extremely close almost within the range
of statistical error but you still get
the Tootsie Roll
yeah
thanks
again follow the crowds uh it's uh two
blocks Uptown and uh we'll get a chance
to talk about the debate
foreign